وضع المتأنق الأجنبي الطفل أسفل وضع الطفل
أسفل الرجل الذي يحمل هذا الطفل البالغ من العمر 23 شهرًا
هو والد الطفل
براندون الوحيد الذي هو الآن قيد الاعتقال بعد
أن اختطف الطفل الصغير من
صديقته والدة الطفل
واستخدام الطفل كدرع بشري
إفادة خطية من
مكتب مأمور مقاطعة فلاجلر بولاية فلوريدا تفيد
أنه كان لديه سلاح ناري أثناء قيادته السيارة بعيدًا
عن المنزل الذي شاركوه وانتهى به الأمر في
مطاردة عالية السرعة أدت إلى
مطعم الوجبات السريعة هذا في بالم كوست فلوريدا على بعد
حوالي 12 ميلاً جنوب منطقتهم.  منزل
الطفل الذي تم تحديده فقط على أنه BL لم
يصب بأذى ولكن تحذير من أن ما
توشك أن تراه هو عنيف ومزعج
ضع الطفل في الأسفل وضع الطفل أسفل
[موسيقى]
أطلق النائب صاعقة كهربائية
يتم إنقاذ الطفل
[  موسيقى]
أذهب إلى شاحنة فلويد أخرى ،
لكن براندون لونر لم
يتوقف ، والصبي الصغير الباكي
يدعو والده
[موسيقى]
نشر Tango ، ينشأ مشهد مجنون
مع النواب في The Barking canin
لا يزال يحاول إلقاء القبض على
المشتبه به
في الإفادة الخطية ، ويقول نائب عمدة الشرطة إن
المشتبه به أخبره لاحقًا أنه قرر
الاستيلاء على طفله ومغادرة منزله عندما
نظر إليه أحد الجيران بشكل غريب
مما منحه ردود فعل غريبة
، حيث تصرح الشهادة الخطية أن المشتبه به
استمر في ذلك.  قاوم على الرغم من إعطائه
اقتباسًا
صوتيًا عاليًا وأوامرًا مشروعة ، وقد تعرض مرة أخرى لقيود الأصفاد
أخيرًا بعد أن تورط
الكلب ، تمت معالجة براندون لونر بسبب
عضات كلبه ، وقد تم اتهامه بأربع
جنايات بما في ذلك اختطاف قاصر
جاري توتشمان سي إن إن أتلانتا